any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody to this episode of
into the impossible
i just finished recording the episode
you're about to listen to i want to
say this was a very interesting
conversation for me i had not yet had on
someone with the experience of
commanding a two billion dollar vehicle
and then such as the uss santa fe which
was captain marquez previous
assignment and uh and yet he has this
humility servant leadership
uh trait that's allowed him to really um
speak to the hearts of the people that
he works with he's working now as a
consultant
advisor i want to uh really just just
you know say how much i appreciated his
time
and uh his team has graciously allowed
us to have a giveaway for uh residents
of the united states or air post office
boxes if you're in the military
so we have a lot of military guests on
the show uh
you will hopefully have a link that you
can download and give
for a giveaway of captain markey's book
uh his new book leadership is language i
have it on audio
and on uh and then the physical world
right here
i'm going to give an introduction to him
i didn't want to spend
his valuable time reading his
introduction because it's so extensive
i'm going to do it now
uh so l david marquet is an author is
student of leadership and organizational
design
he's a former nuclear submarine
commander and was named one of the top
100 leadership speakers by
inc magazine david is the author of the
amazon number one bestseller turn the
ship around
and turn the ship around workbook i have
not read that
the workbook but i'm actually gonna pick
it up right now
david's recently released book
leadership his language is a wall street
journal bestseller
david marquet imagines a workplace where
everyone engages and contributes to
their full intellectual capacity
a place where people are healthier and
happier because they have more control
over their work
a place where everyone is a leader and
just breaking away from the
publicity materials that he sent me his
team sent me
there's uh really a special message
encoded in this
in this podcast and maybe even in the
book which is his life's mission you'll
tune in to the end of the
podcast he'll talk about why this book
is so important
outside of leadership and it really uh
touched me to hear his response so stay
tuned for that
uh david's a 1981 u.s naval academy
graduate
and he served in the u.s submarine
forces for 28 years
after being assigned to command the
nuclear-powered submarine the uss santa
fe
which was then ranked last in retention
and operational standing
he realized the traditional leadership
approach of take control give
orders would not work he turned the ship
around by treating his crew as leaders
not followers
and giving control not taking control
this approach took the santa fe from
worst to first achieving the highest
retention
and operational standings in the navy
after captain marquez departure the
santa fe continued to win awards
promoted a disproportionate number of
officers
and enlisted mental leadership positions
including 10 subsequent submarine
captains
and i can tell it was one of his highest
honors for him
that he not only had many followers but
he created
many more leaders and in the previous
book in this book
there's a forward by stephen covey who i
believe has since passed away
unfortunately
and this book says i don't know of a
finer model of this kind of empowering
leadership than
captain marquet and in the pages that
follow you'll find a model for your
pathway
it's also by joe de bono
he called it the hunt for red october
meets harvard business school
simon sinek said david marquez the kind
of leader comes around once in a
generation
so this book is really a precursor i
would read this first if you're going to
read it maybe get the workbook i'm going
to go buy that now
i'll put links in the show notes so you
can get it too and then remember to
enter into the contest i'll promote that
on social media and he will as well
uh and then just lastly the team sent me
what is the message of this new playbook
for
leaders uh called leadership is language
and
really he says it's time to ditch the
industrial age playbook of leadership
this book provides a structure as well
as specific language for dramatically
improving decision making and execution
for teams
in addition to being a wall street
journal and washington post bestseller
leadership in
his language has been named the business
book of the month by the financial times
so i think what was so uh exciting for
me to talk about him and obviously talk
about scientific leadership academic
leadership
is this notion uh that we're all leaders
and we can lead in any level
and the ways and tools that he describes
and how to do that
um are actionable and you can do that uh
at any level in your family in your
friends uh
in the military even if you're not you
know chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff
uh you can do it and he really gives you
in this new book leadership is language
the number one tool which is this unique
ability that human beings have to
communicate and uh
and so i i hope you'll enjoy this
episode with
uh captain l david markey u.s navy
retired
and uh i hope you'll uh enjoy like
subscribe
comment all those good things keep this
podcast going let me know what you like
about it
and let me know what other guests you'd
like me to have on the show
thanks very much now pleased to present
captain l david marquet leadership as
language on the into the impossible
podcast
welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast i am your
lately very fearful host as i say
uh brian keating co-director of ucsd's
arthur c
clarke center for human imaginations
into the impossible podcast where we
talk to great leaders and thinkers
scientists
artists poets yesterday captain you'll
be
pleased to know i talked to a nasa
astronaut my second one the first one i
talked to dr jessica mear
she i talked to from the international
space station but you're
also calling in from where nicole stott
astronaut stop that i spoke to yesterday
called in from
which is florida so first captain how
are you doing in florida
good i'm fine i'm like
being home i'm an i'm an introvert and a
geek so hey this is great that's like
you know
montezuma's revenge or something it's uh
both you guys it was scary getting
together with people yeah i know
i was thinking well you know for a lot
of our friends i always joke you know
how do you know if a scientist is
an extrovert because he looks at your
shoes instead of his own shoes
and i like to be with my fellow
fellow geeks and and nerds especially
ones such as yourself who's
taught me so much uh you didn't know
this but i read
the previous book turned the ship around
and just devoured
uh this book called leadership is
language uh
reportedly i think i heard that you were
going to call this the five love
languages
of leadership but maybe maybe that's not
true
we had a lot of titles yeah so i always
ask my guests actually let's segue right
into that
uh the advice is never judge a book by
its cover but i always judge all books
by their cover
because i'm just human right so how'd
you come up with the title uh actually
for this uh for this book your most
recent book but let's actually start
with
turn the ship around and the coverage
was easy
it was um
i was uh this was like five years before
i wrote it
i was still in the navy i was doing uh
anyway i was i was talking to various
people
i had a job at one point where i was a
liaison up in manhattan to business
groups and that was really interesting
because i got to meet all these
business people and financial people
hedge fund people whatever anyway so i'm
telling kind of my
story my thoughts what's going on and
uh one guy just blurts out he said oh
yeah yeah
i'll give you the title of your book
turn the ship around as soon as he
said that i said yeah that's it and then
of course
you have the scene in star wars where
leia's coming back or there and they say
turn the ship around and they got to
come back to pick up luke he's dangling
from that
thing and so if you type and turn the
ship around you'll either get my book or
you get a scene from star wars
yeah we love it here and our arthur c
clarke would be proud to hear that
and then leadership is language uh
subtitle the hidden power of what you
say
and what you don't and i think i
understand the symbolism of the colors
but can you talk us through the title
and uh what it means to you so
at one point i want to call it the new
playbook for leadership or have the
subtitle be a playbook because
here's the way i think about it i
uh as i went through my leadership stuff
i kept it's all about inter how you
interact with people leadership's always
about
other people so and how do you do that
we do it through language
so if you're a paint if you're a painter
you use
paint if you're a bricklayer you use
bricks and
mortar if you're a leader you use words
and it always seemed to me like we
99 of leadership programs got shy of
saying the actual words we would say
things like well you need to communicate
more you need
to care of your people you need a blah
blah blah like well what do you actually
like what is what do you say how do you
make that happen
you need to empower your people and so
for me i
i started making this big list of don't
say this say that
so for example when you ask a question
someone comes up to you and says
i i i think that's a bad idea
and your reaction is now let me explain
let me let me let me tell you
or you might say if you were enlightened
feeling enlightened that day well why do
you think that
anyway none of these i don't think are
very good responses
uh what you want to be is curious not
compelling so
and and even if you said are you sure
that's still not that helpful because
the response still doesn't tell you
a whole lot i would argue yes i'm sure
what does that even mean if it's about
the future you can't be sure
you and i are physicists so we know
everything is probabilistic
every yeah in the future anyway maybe
in the past but we'll let that be anyway
so
so i would say well don't say are you
sure ask how sure are you don't ask is
it safe ask
how safe is it and so i kept starting
making this big list
and it turns out there's a there's a
underlying pattern
all these different things that we say
and the pattern is
they're structured from an industrial
age
era with the objective two objectives
one is to reduce variability
collapse variability and uncertainty as
soon as possible which often means
prematurely
and two there's a coercive nature
because the industrial age
organization was designed so that one
group of people
made decisions and a different group of
people just
had to implement the decisions that were
determined by the first group of people
and it looks like this this is your
industrial age factory you have all
these people these are people doing what
they're told
and this one person over here the
foreman is the person who's telling
people
what to do so the point is in that model
it's all cool it's coercive we don't say
it we use all it's motivational it's
inspirational whatever
but it's fundamentally about getting
someone else to do something you decided
they needed to do
and it hit me like a light like
just a ton of bricks like that's the
model it doesn't have to be that way
we can let the people who are doing the
work make decisions about the work how
do we do that
we know it's better and it came out
through language and so i
what i think is my hypothesis
is that our language is an industrial
age language and you can do everything
you want to claim to be in an
enlightened workplace and then like
leader but unless you
actually change the words you say now
this is the easiest and the hardest
thing to do
you don't need software you don't need
to change the laws of physics but you
have to change your habits
and there's so many people myself
included
that you just stuck and you
you're stuck in the patterns
there's some people for example who like
to say the word right
so they're there right and then they're
right and then
right no
wrong why do we have to well first of
all why are we saying right
it's a coercion it's a micro coercion to
piggyback in another genre it's a micro
coercion because
it's just saying if you don't think this
is right you're
the odd person out you and and i just
make it a little harder for people to
disagree yeah the structure of meetings
where we talk about something and then
we vote
is inherently coercive because the
conversation makes it harder for uh
for the outliers to speak up we
want it to be because i'm not really
truly honestly interested
in a real conversation so i say hey we
should launch 737 max software right i
mean
we've done a lot of testing testing all
come on i mean you told me yeah it does
look good
it's very important airbus is getting
ahead of us ready to go right yeah
yeah what do you guys think uh uh huh
no so it's all upside down it's the
culture yeah and uh
i usually don't it's the words it's the
words not
right but i'm saying yeah we're stuck in
this culture
from culture and it all starts with the
word that you say
yeah so i'm an educator you know my day
job as an educator my night job is doing
podcasts
uh but uh but you know and i usually
don't push back against my uh
my guests that i'm very honored to have
so early in the conversation but i'm
going to push back a little bit so
um i'm an educator and the educational
system in america
uh and throughout the western world i
don't know so much about other parts of
the world
it's still this industrial even
pre-industrial model where you're
training people to be in that factory
setup
just like you displayed on your virtual
background a couple of minutes ago
and uh and i'm and that language is also
extremely important you can't teach
somebody if you don't have
sort of a notion of no i don't want to
say love but but i feel like you have to
have
a certain amount of affection the
maslow's hierarchy you talked about this
before
but uh but you have to have physical
safety you have to have some kind of
emotional connection you can't say like
you're gonna i mean your drill sergeants
or whatever you have equivalent in the
navy
the same thing you know i don't think
that's the most important language to
communicate
teaching in a way that's going to
penetrate into the soul
of the receiver and i guess my my
pushback to you
is if the educational system which every
leader had to go through the educational
system
and if that hasn't changed in 250 plus
years
why are you optimistic that we can
change a higher order meta skill like
leadership
based on language if we can't even get
the preceding
uh amount of education change in the way
that we use language as educators
well i don't think you're pushing back i
didn't say i was optimistic
okay all right fine yeah i i
i it's gonna change um
and first of all i totally agree with
you
a lot of these things are not obvious if
you're picturing the drill sergeant
that's the wrong picture like that's
obvious coercion and it's played for a
certain reason
well these are things that we say not
meaning to be this way
but our patterns of speech so if i
ask you well i i so i consult a bunch of
big companies and they run a meeting and
they make a decision i said well how why
did you run the meeting that way
why did you discuss it and then vote and
why was the vote like a binary roman
vote why didn't you ask a probabilistic
vote
and why didn't you ask the vote at the
beginning no one
i don't know it's just the way we do it
people are no one's thinking
they're just unthinkingly repeating the
same thing and so if you go back that
so we're unthinkingly repeating stuff
from 100 years ago because
all the way in between no one ever stood
up and said
this is not helping my cause so first of
all yeah the education system is part of
it things are changing i mean there are
there are education there are
spotlights and we know companies and
they're changing but
it's it always starts with the with with
with you and we always have awkward
conversation with leadership they're
like oh
we allow you to come in and fix our
people
teach them to speak up teach them to
think creatively
like i'm pretty sure they're already
thinking creatively they're just keeping
their heads kind of a thing yeah i was
like okay well let's start with you guys
no no we're fine i ordered them to speak
up it's not me like okay got it
click anyway so yeah so
it's gonna be hard but what's gonna
happen is the companies don't
that don't operate this way are
eventually going to go out of business
you can you can make a lot of money for
a long time but eventually it's all got
to collapse
because the the leader is going to leave
so so the leader could create a system
where i'm the key decision maker
like jack welch and you can tell these
people because it's a very
personality-based thing jack welch is
the
name one of the vice presidents right
you can't do it
yeah because you never heard about that
the jack jack was never talked about
them really talk about himself
and so then we push and put our covers
on the pictures
our picture on the cover of our books
and then the thing falls apart
a after he leaves or b because the
things are in play so it's not
replicated
now apple with steve jobs is kind of an
interesting and different story
i think yeah you know i never met them
but i read
the different biographies on they they
kind of pay
a pretty brutal picture
but there was there's something going on
there because they're still doing very
very
obviously very well this wouldn't be the
case if they're all
if it was steve jobs if he was he was
the guy
yeah i mean that might oh itself also
the different culture in silicon valley
as you talk about in the book towards
the end of the book you know
uh when leaders are fearful of granting
authority
and even the communications delegation
to younger people
in particular you make this point they
do themselves a disservice because
it might be that a younger person yeah
they're not he or she might not be a
senior as the leaders quote unquote
and this holds for experiments this
holds for department chairs and academia
which i want to get to
but actually they're doing themselves
this service by creating this sort of
cult of personality as you say
it dies with them and you give the point
of you know gordon moore
and um and and also andy grove and
talking about
they would do these kind of exercises
where they'd ask themselves
and what we call as physicists a
godankin experiment a thought experiment
how would the company look if we
suddenly disappeared not gruesomely just
they're gone you know maybe they got a
bigger better offer yeah and i wonder
say they got him to save they saved
intel because intel was a memory
chip maker and they decided to go into
processors and there was a critical
moment
when uh gord moore turns andy grove and
says well what if we
imagine we'd both be fired and they
brought in two new people to run the
company what would they do
and he's like well that's easy we get we
ship from memory to
microprocessors well what like that's a
brilliant
why is it so easy to do because i
psychologically detached myself from my
previous
decisions and this is one of the key
things that happens
in organizations once the per once you
make a decision your
your emotion your ego now attaches to
that
and so now you are you are contaminated
you no longer can dispassionately
evaluate that decision
and we have lots of examples in history
that's called escalation of commitment
as you probably know so we keep pouring
effort into proving that yale was right
blah blah blah yeah
doing print film of course we got rich
making print film we're going to keep
doing print film print films the future
even though it's not everyone else knows
it we might even know it but we can't
you can't just because we were we were
the people who did print film
yeah what's interesting to me are the
counter exam i mean there's just a few
but you look at microsoft
and they basically put no energy in into
the web they kind of thought it was a
passing fancy
and they're one of the few count to
kodak you know versus instagram or
something like that
that were nimble because i think they
had a vision
of themselves with a leadership mindset
and again i mean bill gates
is was at least for a long time the real
focal point of that organization and so
it is sort of surprising
a they've done better maybe since he's
left in some ways
and b that they were surviving these
huge uh
strategic mistakes not just the tactical
mistakes and we'll get into the el faro
but since we already started it down
this road um
when i i mentioned just before we
started recording i'm a pilot
and uh just a hobby pilot uh hopefully i
i am in training to get my cfi my
certified flight instructor
certificates i'm a commercial pilot i'm
going to try to become a flight
instructor
mainly so i could teach my kids someday
how to fly little cessnas around
uh but uh but we're taught very early on
uh and it's actually funny to me
captain you'll be amused in the whole
federal register of documents i believe
that there's only one place
where they talk about you know someone's
emotions and their feelings and maslow's
hierarchy of needs
and it's an faa federal document on how
to be a flight instructor and it talks
about like the need for love and the
need for say i just think it's funny
like you wouldn't find this in the irs
you know handbook for auditors you know
here's how you're
you have to make your oddity feel feel
uh loved and welcome but anyway
uh yeah we're taught that the most
dangerous words we can say is
captain i'm gonna see you uh at the
airport at 503 pm
uh exactly on sunday afternoon uh don't
be late i'm not going to be late
it's called get there itis and i feel
like uh that's another name maybe for
this escalation of commitment sort of a
sunk cost fallacy with pilots it's
extremely dangerous
because we'll just get tunnel vision
we'll just ignore the weather oh there's
a huge buildup give me a little build up
over there oh there's the airport's got
a no tam there's a tfr the president
and we just ignore it we have to be
there because i made this commitment you
know i'm going to meet the captain there
i don't want to be late and i i get my
ego invested in it and i think
these biases that you talk about in the
book they're so pernicious
and yet i i just feel like they're hard
work maybe this is another thing that
we're both not optimistic about i don't
know
but these things are so hard wired in
that we have names for them
these fallacies and biases are you
sanguine at all
that the human mind especially in the
leadership high stakes corporate world
or even academia that we can overcome
these lizard-like reactions that our
brains all
are subjective to subject to
yeah so so the play we call the play
you're describing we call
obey the clock we have work we have
clockwork
we we clock many many people
still clock in and clock out why
because it's an industrial age construct
it was about obeying the clock
now the problem is when you're obeying
the clock as you knows from flight
instructor
your brain exactly how you described it
you get tunnel focus on the and you
don't
it's not like you see the clouds you say
no i'm not gonna pay attention to the
storm
to the weather head over there it's like
you don't even see it
and so what you want to do as a leader
is control the clock control
for your team you're the leader of the
one that's got to say all right everyone
stop put your pencils down
and we now need to
raise our heads and turn left and right
and scan the horizon
and decide what to do then we'll go back
it's good to be focused and committed on
the work
for bulk periods of time that
but be super focused what happens is p
organizations don't define
this is a focus time this is broad
perspective time so what happens is
while i'm focused i need to reserve a
little bit of my cognitive ability to be
scanning so i'm only 90
into it and because there's only partly
out of it then
i'm i'm liable to miss stuff and then
there's no rhythm so the whole thing
about
the new book is in these plays you've
got to be
laser focused but then super broad be
looking at the
uh looking at the horizon but there was
something else you said that
what was the last thing you ended up
with uh
just a psychological biases that we're
all subject to
oh yeah yeah so look
so we have
instinctive responses to things
and as the world gets more and more
complicated
your million years of dna
has no
chance context of this thing
so what's happening is
our biological wiring is many times
needs to be overridden by a more
level-headed cognitive
thinking that kahneman talks about
system one and system two it's
it's not just condom but it's a common
like we have our instinct immediate
reaction
i'll give you an example though racism
we're wired to be suspicious of people
from the other tribe
someone who looks differently than me
that's a mark
marker the person's from another tribe
now we have been we as a race
have been working diligently in my
opinion not
some more than others to
create systems to make it fair for
everybody because we recognize the
conscious brain recognizes that's
evil that's not
good there's no reason for me to be
suspicious
of this person and so i have the i have
some of this
instinct but then i have to override it
as a human
and in our policies
we say well you know i can write
policies when i'm in calm clear cool
collected
uh thinking mode
i'm not in a dark alley i don't have i
don't have my
prima primordial fears
triggering behaviors
and so then i can write policies that
will help me
not fall into these traps
yeah i so anyway it's it's like maybe
it's taken longer than
it should have but
just like i think we can be better
but there is some there is some deep
deep down wiring
that is no longer helpful for us and
uh ten thousand generations from now
it'll be gone
all right we've got a lot we gotta get
from here today
what do you make of uh you know this uh
say
say we're um speaking to a young
middle manager or associate professor or
somebody who wants to
you know move up in the in the corporate
or academic ladder
uh there are all these gatekeepers you
know ahead of her
and and she's not really in charge of
her own destiny so she may read these
books and just benefit as i did
you know i'm blessed to be you know
co-leading with uh some of the most
brilliant scientists around
uh this huge you know 100 million dollar
project called the simon's observatory
in the high atacama desert of chile
and uh and and those people are are so
brilliant my co-leaders of the
experiment and
all the people that work for us let's
say somebody has a suggestion
uh they may be a graduate student they
may be a
assistant professor you know lower in
the pecking order you know equivalent to
a
you know lieutenant or captain or not a
captain and not in the navy obviously
but
lieutenant commander or something like
that but not at the level where they can
actually
turn the ship around uh so it's so to
speak
uh what do you mean like it's it's
frustrating when i i remember what it's
like i know more than this person
uh and yet they knew me when i was a you
know what what do you call the you know
the ensigns the pukes or
whatever you call the scab scallywag i
don't even know but uh but
they knew me when i knew nothing and so
how are they ever going to revise
that image that mental model that they
constructed which is another bias
uh but how can you actually empower
somebody in minimum or
i guess what i'm asking are these books
only for like the jack welch's
you know they should have read this book
uh or how can someone who's not in the
apex of the pyramid yet you know how can
she
make a change and effectuate the great
wisdom of the books
well you influence you you influence in
your family
you influence in your
division or if you don't in your
department have been our department head
and your division if you're not
in your squad if you're just a team
member you can influence
to in a positive way the people to the
left and the right
of you and you can maybe even influence
upward you can find there are things in
this book that i think will help you be
heard the big
the problem is people just try and have
influence
and they skip the earner so it's always
a two-step
earn the right to be heard then have
influence and people say well that's
that's
going to take time it's going to be
annoying they should just trust that i'm
a brilliant genius
and smarter than them and they need to
listen to me nah it doesn't work like
that so
f1 earned the right to be heard step two
have influence so
i yeah therefore uh
if you deal with human beings in your
life then i'm
then there's something in here for you
yeah we have a lot of people
talk about in
how this works in their families yeah
no i can definitely see that i mean i
was just after reading the book
yesterday i was talking to my oldest son
and he's you know he's really interested
in these podcasts and so forth and he's
like you know what makes a good
interview data and i said well look at
you know look at what god or nature if
you
if you prefer gave you you know you have
two ears and you have one mouth
and basically that's a it's a hint that
you should listen you know basically
twice as much as you talk so i hope i'm
doing that
but uh but i i agree when you say earn
the right to be heard that's really just
like first you have to
listen and then you can speak so it's
kind of like the two to one ratio almost
embodied exactly what you're saying
um i want to talk and then of course
there's this notion you mentioned in
your book
that leaders speak last and and it goes
through with these tools and i love the
fact that you give not only the strategy
you know the kind of uh 30 000 furlongs
or i don't know what you guys talk about
but
but the really big picture view you know
we'd say 30 000 feet as a pilot but um
you give the the strategic overview but
more important i think are the tactics
that you give
so i thought we maybe we could go
through just one quick one you talk
about the cards and i'll
have a link to some exercises that my
listeners can apply so that they can
viscerally feel that but talk about the
fist to five because
i want to use that to riff on something
that i came up with that has to do with
of all things
the second law of thermodynamics after
this but talk about fist to five
how you came up with it or how you apply
it and
how it benefits leadership as well so
one of our clients is a global
construction company
and for anyone in construction anyone
can imagine a construction
site there's a lot of top-down
do-it-yourself kind of stuff
and every morning the team gets together
so i was
uh i would observe these meetings and so
one morning
i was in boston observing a meeting and
it was a bunch of carpenters
and the foreman walks in and
he's a little bit of a younger guy but
he takes a very gruff
tone he uses the f-bomb about 15 times
in a
five-minute so we're going to do this
this this this this this
uh you good go
now you good that's not really a
question
you i wouldn't put a question mark after
it if i were writing it
it means you better be good
and you're on your way and i'm not it no
one had any questions
right the safety head safety guy got up
and he said
he asked six questions immediately in a
row immediately went on the next one so
you got the tools you need right you
don't want anyone's heart hat to blow up
do you and
like again no one said anything 40
people
no one said anything and afterwards i
was like
dude were you really looking for
responses to those questions
well yeah they're just uh the problem is
these are these binary questions is it
say uh is it safe
yeah yeah are you sure yeah so you gotta
say
how safe is it so we changed it so on
the on the construction
site because no one's going to no one
literally
no one's going to say it's not safe to
work today we have a storm blowing in we
have five new people we're going up on
the third deck
there's no railings it's not safe but if
you ask
every day you say how safe is it zero to
five and people going five five
five and then one day they say four it's
easy to do that
now you're like oh something's changed
um we were talking to a doctor's
organization in seattle so this one
coveted hit
and uh one enlightened doctor started
asking her team the rest of them were
like
you guys are good right you're good
right and they would all say
yeah they would all pretend to be good
they weren't good
they were nervous some of them had when
and when they had elderly parents they
would go home so be exposed as
healthcare workers they would go home
and interact with elderly parents they
were super scared
so this one doctor says how safe do you
feel not
are you safe and they're putting up
one person puts up with zero that takes
guts
but a zero you know first of all thank
you you're the first person ever asked
me that
and number two and she told the story it
was with this el
i my my mom lives with me if i get sick
she's gonna die i will know that i
killed her can i
work in a dif can i do something anyway
so
the idea so that's fits to five you
gotta ask your questions in a
probabilistic way we say start the
question with the word how.
don't tell people just so that that'll
make your questions better right
yeah i was thinking about that you know
when you go to a restaurant and you ask
the server you know what's your favorite
dish well you're just getting
a you know a sample of one but if you
say what's the most popular dish
then you're getting a sample of every
person that that server has interacted
with now it's not not as
high as stakes as dealing with covet or
dealing with the ship the other thing
that that really
inspired me to think about is i've heard
it asked you know on a scale of one to
ten
you know almost everybody will say seven
you know no matter what it is because
seven's safe seven's cozy
you know it's not too far away from ten
so you're not insulting somebody
and it's not so far away from five that
you know five is almost awful
out of a ten point so you basically say
you know on a scale of you know one to
ten
but you can't pick seven uh what would
you assign the probability exactly as
you're saying and i think
those kinds of exercises are extremely
valuable because
a lot of times yeah you don't want to
stick your neck up those are the people
that get shot
um speaking of fingers and and uh and
your hand
i wanted to just you know uh remind you
because you're you've got
had you know training in physics that
the
second law of thermodynamics states that
you know entropy is always increasing
and the reason for that you know your
coffee will very
uh often stay mixed up with the cream
but it'll almost never separate into a
state of pure cream
and pure coffee because there's only one
such state whereas there's an infinite
number of combinations of
multiple states and i like to take
people through an exercise you know
how many pairs of interactions you know
can you have in an organization with n
elements in it so if there's a you know
a sub has what 80 people on it captain
something like that
40. 140. so how many pairs of
interactions are there well it's easier
to start with your fist start with your
hand
so if you have five people on the
submarine how many combinations are
there well this guy can pair up with
this one this one this one and this one
and so you go through it and it's four
plus three plus two plus one different
combinations there's ten combinations
and actually the pairs of of of contacts
scale as the square of the number
so it made me think what i was reading
and that's kind of like the entropy of
leadership like
the num it isn't at least in my opinion
the organization is actually built up of
pairs of networks
and then the network as a whole you know
can be influenced by
any one pair but uh but it doesn't have
the influence of the n squared
and so you kind of cost benefit when is
the number it's n squared divided by n
but i wonder you know in uh in in this
regime
is it more important as a leader to work
on those like interpersonal i've heard
it said you know lincoln was such a
great
uh you know jim simons who's the patron
of our experiment the simon's
observatory
he says lincoln's his favorite leader of
all time even human being of all time
because he would go out and he would mix
with the troops he would create those
bonding pairs i just talked about
what like single straight besides in
addition to language perhaps
uh or maybe in the context of language
when you're talking
uh is the most important you know trait
or tactic or skill to use in order to be
a successful leader
well i'm guessing lincoln's relationship
with grant was more important than a
relationship with a common
soldier but those interactions are
important because when they aggregate
that soldier will talk to other soldiers
and he may
lincoln may learn something that he
wouldn't have learned if
feeling he's talking to grant and alec
and the
rest of the union leaders
so i think you
[Music]
my i the thing i just keep going back to
is why did you ask
why did you say it that way why did you
use those words
99 of the time people shrug their
shoulders
so really in-depth listening deep
listening
and uh deliberate speaking
if you're going to speak just
decide how you're going to say what is
the question you're going to ask and how
are you going to ask
um captain i know we just have a few
more minutes if you'll indulge me off
some questions from my audience uh so
one member of my audience
as uh is a practicing jew
and one of the worst uh offenses that a
person can commit in judaism
is what's called lashon horror which
means literally an evil tongue
and there's a parable said that when uh
a rabbi was disparaged
in in the ancient uh not ancient but in
you know the shtetls of eastern europe
in the 1800s
and somebody told some gossip about this
rabbi
and then the the rabbi found out about
it his reputation was ruined
and as a leader in the community and he
asked the congregant or whoever it was
uh to go see him when when the
congregant decided he was he wanted to
apologize to the rabbi so the rabbi said
uh you can apologize to me and make
amends very easily and the current oh
thank you so much i feel so bad
how do i do it rabbi the rabbi said get
a pillow a feather pillow and cut it
open
and then uh and uh and the guy said okay
that's kind of weird
uh but he cut it open and then he said
uh shake it out
and he shook it out and the feather
started flying around and he said now go
gather up all the feathers
and and and that's how you'll make
amends to me basically that it's
impossible so
a question that this listener has is um
you know
let's say you make a mistake and and and
you fail you you failed as a leader in
some so it may not be
you went into the eye of a hurricane
like the uh el faro did
um but but nevertheless you failed and
at some level as a leader as a follower
or somebody
in the community in the organization um
how do you go about
rectifying that the language you know
martin luther king said you know words
that come from the heart enter the heart
you know how how how can we undo
or make amends the maya culpa side of
things as leaders
saving face you know i mean it's is it
possible or you know do you just have to
just soldier on or
you know sail around again i keep
failing at my navel analogies but can
you help our listener kind of deal with
like
failure and letting your letting your uh
letting your team down and then but
wanting to to
have a a teachable lesson from that
experience
well you you can't undo anything that's
obvious it's happened you can try and
have justice or make amends
but it's unless you have some power to
go back in time
that i don't know about i'm working out
in the lab i'm not allowed to talk about
that yeah you're not going to
darpa's not letting me you're not going
to do anything look if you get to the
end of the day and
you know in your head think
oh i could have made this better i could
have been or had this been i could have
asked this better i could have been more
empowering here i could have trusted a
little bit more here
like if you don't have like 10 of those
at the end of the day i think you're
just walking through life clueless
if you don't think every day
now i'm not saying like i made a
decision launch
the columbia shuttle and and people died
i it doesn't need to be that dramatic
but you can make it better you can be
better every day
you you just move on so yeah sometimes
you don't need to apologize just
move forward be be better i
made a public commitment to my team to
be a better leader to not tell them what
my thing was don't give any orders
if i tell you guys what to do you i want
you guys to
to call me out on that i want you to
yellow card me we had referee
card we had a little referee yeah cards
ones were a lot of them
and so you're gonna get feedback but
hiding it no
you're not gonna wanna they're gonna be
dysfunctional look
whatever behavior you do they're gonna
do so do you want if your team makes a
mistake do you want them to come tell
you about it or would you rather they
just hide it
yeah okay you you whatever behavior you
do they're gonna do
so if you make a mistake you come clean
say hey i could have done better should
i
i wasn't in a good frame of mind when i
was running this meeting
i didn't really do a very good job
listening in my opinion it was brought
up to me or maybe you just
self-reflecting on it
then it isn't that what you would want
your people to do
well as leaders we have this we have
this arrogant
asymmetry in our perspectives well i'm
gonna be like this but you have to be
like
like that right different standards
shifting zeitgeist for the the
followers versus the leader but i don't
know a single leader who wasn't a
follower
and i don't know a single leader who
never failed at something you know if
you even look at uh
you know how many baseball teams win the
world series every single year
for all eternity and no one so you know
getting succeeding and dealing with that
um
it brings up another question for me to
you uh if you indulge me and then we'll
get onto these final
three questions um how do you deal with
the letdown i mean you had the keys to a
two billion dollar vehicle uh what was
that like when you stepped down i mean i
know it was also the beginning of
another career for you
but uh what is that like emotionally i
mean you got to the promised land so few
people in
in that industry so to speak get to
there um was it a letdown
how do you deal with it is it just your
character you're just like i'm just
going to get to work the next day start
writing the book
no i didn't write the book for 10 years
because it took 10 years
the reason i wrote the book was not
because we turned the worst submarine
into the best and we went to the worst
the best morale is because 10 years
later
we created more submarine commanders
than any other submarine
and this is what's lost i mean to turn
the ship around is just the hook
to get you to buy it but the real story
is about creating leaders but again
listen to the language
when you stepped down
why not when i stepped up or stepped
away
but the language the language builds in
these emotional
uh interpretations that
look when i look leaving the submarine
it was that was
awesome but i was on the next phase of
my life which was in this case
i was inspecting i stayed in the navy
for another 10 years wow
i was the inspector of other submarines
and you moved to
places of bigger scale
so uh just the last thing i'll say on
that there's a famous rabbi in judaism
uh the laboratories the head of the
chabad movement of judaism
and he was rumored to say you know a
good leader
creates a massive number of followers
but a great leader creates a massive
number of leaders and
and i think that that's uh sort of in
harmony with the message of uh turn the
ship around
uh the last good leaders
create more leaders yes here's the
question
following what because it makes a big
difference i think that is a thought
experiment
yeah another good dankin experiment okay
uh okay i was
just about to call you rabbi but that's
uh another honorific captain
uh captain markay let me just uh finish
up with the questions that i
ask of all my guests if you'll indulge
me for a couple more minutes
uh first one has to do with a concept
that we call an ethical will
and you may know that alfred nobel had a
will that endowed the famous nobel
prizes
and in that will he said the prizes
should go for the greatest discovery or
invention in physics chemistry etc
but he also said that the award should
be for something
that benefited mankind in other words
the will was not just a material will
giving away his swedish kroner
but it was also an ethical will it was
giving wisdom or advice
or conveying a message to humanity that
he most uh
wanted them to adhere to and and in fact
that
lesson has probably been heeded more
than the
impact of his financial uh munificence
so
i want to ask you uh captain uh if
you're gonna leave an ethical will not
your material will what would you leave
as a wisdom as a
as a as a brief inheritance to future
generations
uh that you've accumulated from your
wisdom or advice uh
so far on this planet
i wanna i want work to not suck for so
many people
i want people to be able to go to work i
want people to be able to be fully human
say what they think not worry about
being judged not
feel psychologically safe don't worry
about being second guessed
not worry about being judged based on
how old you are to color your skin
and to go home
free of toxins and free of stress so
that you don't carry that out
on your family and the problem isn't
evil people there are a few evil people
and
we'll get them sorted out but
the problem is the vast majority of
people who are just doing
the same thing that their grandparents
did which was okay for their time but
we can do so much better now or not yeah
i'm kind of hoping that this book as i
said there's more people that go through
the education system that become then
become leaders but maybe the top down
approach
isn't working maybe we can change
education if we change our leadership
models
and language is the is the first step as
you point out second question captain
revolves around uh arthur c clarke's
a space odyssey his book turned into a
movie stanley kubrick where the movie
features an opening
uh really you know canonical scene of
all time these monoliths these giant
structures that are
you know really meant to be discovered
by humankind placed there by an ancient
unseen civilization
as sort of a time capsule encapsulating
something objective a material object or
what have you i want to ask you
if you could plant a monolith on some
other planet or even on earth
it's going to last for a billion years
it's your billion-year time capsule
what would you put in it on it what
would it be
well i don't know about other planets
but on earth it would be think for
yourself
good enough i think that's fantastic
and uh last question uh
really revolves around the second law a
third law of arthur c clarke
which was the only way to find out what
is possible is to venture out
a little bit beyond into the impossible
so
now we're going backwards in time we had
two about future of
of your contributions and then the
future of
perhaps the uh the planet uh now going
back in time advice to your former self
what
seemed impossible to you once and now
is eminently possible because you
ventured a little bit into the
impossible
me uh well i will tell you that uh
i grew up during the cold war and that
just seemed like that was gonna define
life forever and then it ended one day
and it was
amazing and it seemed like we'd stepped
away from
we didn't have to do hide under our desk
and do
nuclear
and that was because reagan and
gorbachev were
maybe able to step outside of their
traditional roles
gorbachev in particular i think gives it
a huge amount of credit
for for that
and that's not such a personal story but
i did dedicated my
i mean i went into the military because
of the the soviet threat
i believed in the constitution and our
role in defending it
and i spent hours and hours and days and
days and weeks and weeks
thinking about how to defeat them if we
ever had to go to war
and then all of a sudden it was over
well that's uh that's actually a helpful
note to end on
because you know thinking about the
generation of kids growing up with
this anxiety fear of you know covet etc
there's uh there's going to be light at
the end of the tunnel and i think it's
fitting you discuss your
patriotic commitment i want to thank you
for your service we're hopefully going
to release this episode on july 4th
uh befitting the uh great contributions
that you've made to the country
not just in terms of your service and
commitment to the
armed forces but also to training and
inspiring the next generation of leaders
and benefiting as you say this follow-on
effect that we don't know the butterfly
effect you help a leader at work
he or she has a better family life
you're going to multiply
the vote as we say uh captain i want to
thank you so much for sharing your time
i know we went a little bit over but i
really appreciate it
thanks and thanks for having me on your
podcast thanks for all the listeners out
there thanks for what you guys do to
make the world a better place
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review
for a chance to win a free copy of our
most recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences at the university of california
san
diego eric very director
brian keating co-director patrick
coleman associate director
produced by stuart valco